here's the thing about Tampa and Ybor
City and I want to shout out to
everybody because when you go when
you're on seventh Avenue there or maybe
it's seventh Street who gives a [ __ ]
Ethel but it's Ybor City there's
something about that strip where people
on a Saturday on a Friday night will get
in there in their trucks and they have
speakers that are about there's wide as
the widest dish and then what they want
you to know that they like that blast
that music so it's reverberating yeah
and they that's what they're doing a
little old ears hurts my little ears but
then there's a guy behind him on a
motorcycle with even louder speakers I'm
st. John it sure is it's Eric walking
why do you think they do it though
because they they don't read no or you
maybe it has to be an ego thing because
it's like the guy on the motorcycle like
already your motorcycle add enough yeah
but then the mysterious blast it's so
high well it's not nineteen so you know
they can do Bluetooth radio from there
to your helmet yeah so we all don't have
to listen your but yeah but know that
that's like listen these are my speakers
they're literally rolling there they got
rims and they're rolling through to show
you their rims and how loud their music
is but I saw this one guy who couple
these tubes they were like a biker
couple and this dude had like kind of
long hair she's got two thumbs she had
she was just he's on the back big old
piano that big non grace funbags they
were not they were probably 47 but good
and they were doing it there were Road
hogs yup and then and then it's just so
interesting it's just like this it's
kind of a combination of redneck ghetto
it's all this I did it was incredible
it's a weird mean weird that's one guy
rolled up on the bite on his [ __ ]
Harley and he had a this is like two
weeks on LA which is super ballsy they
do uh-huh he had on a American flag
bandana backwards [ __ ] boley's I
haven't seen in forever ah sleeveless
shirt and then amis was Kid Rock going
my name is king
rakh Oh what is that a red light mouths
feeling it though him that's a girl
jealous if that's a guy who's like to
see you guys know I'm here and I
followed LOL that guy [ __ ] dudes no I
like you should always judge as you go
bro you [ __ ] why just why I know you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] yep and then you guys you
go to your point and you give them the
thought he doesn't hear anything yes see
you're here yeah here it doesn't matter
say it anyway to them in hysterics dude
you uh you look at the car next to you
and you go hey this guy [ __ ] like
you're like this this guy [ __ ] [ __ ] up
the moonroof then you go congratulations
dude number one on your speakers on the
choices you're making on [ __ ] going
so sleeves soles is French with without
you're going saw sleeves I mean you're
amazing bro you're hater on those guys
dude yup one catches you and [ __ ] you
real quick Brian do you think you could
I'm just curious cuz you doing push-ups
not everything yeah do you think you
could beat me in arm wrestling I don't
know I'm not that good at it but I'm not
that great at it I just won probably but
I don't know you have a long arm are you
strong I'm definitely strong yeah what I
wonder how I'm gonna arm us [ __ ] we will
do it eventually we're gonna arm wrestle
at that desk or even there wherever King
does this all the time he's always
trying to assert dominance over I'm not
gonna sir I'm just letting people know
Chin's Korean friends are some of the
toughest people in the world they have
Nick Cannon got on to a podcast and
talked to ti the other week about how
when he was married to Mariah Carey
there was some drama between her and
Eminem
because Eminem wrote a track saying that
he used to date Mariah Carey on the low
and that he wants her back she then came
out with a song why are you so obsessed
with me where she dressed up as Eminem
stocking so man he didn't like that so
he made a diss track with her moaning in
the back and I'm did yes and this was
around the time when Nick Cannon just
married Mariah Carey so he said that he
was calling agents and reps to see where
he was because he wanted to find him and
essentially like talk it out
him Jesus that's him going out on the TI
has a podcast Paschal podcasts can begin
there ever too much money TI ho doing
podcasting uh he put I wrote this long
ass letter pretty much saying I expect
you as an artist I'm actually a fan I
think you're one of the best ever do it
but from man to man you talking out of
pocket to my wife you've got to be held
accountable for that so I need to see
face to face I was ready for whatever I
went looking for him because you've done
you done disrespecting my wife I need to
show you my wife I'm a man number one
and then two he said my name I said I
know I'm not gonna be able to out rap
you correct well peel up your ass those
really exact words at the time cooler
heads prevailed
elisee sees what's going on I don't
wanna fight anymore he's still my top
five wife I'd be pissed too
no they're not married they're not
married anymore that's cool you're
saying you've got to be held accountable
for you save say something we're gonna
have to have this conversation like man
that's all I wanted that's cool I'm
gonna Canon fan yeah yeah a trailer park
in Ohio would like like like poor white
poor I like everything you see in the
news and like wow yeah it was it was
just it was like the people across
street from me I remember I went over
their trailer I was like 10 and they had
a catfish in their bathtub and I thought
there was a coolest thing a live catfish
and I came home like catfish in the
bathtub
that's that's you get older like how's
anybody taken aback cool should ever are
they taking a bath and it was like eight
they had like eight kids and they were
surround Gary come back here look that's
crazy was your childhood going I
wouldn't call it that now no I would say
was uh was without stepdad oh you know
and you got the bad stepdad who's really
bad and then Bryan Callen calls you've
all right I wonder why brother Joe by
the way I was the worst wrestler in the
state of Ohio for three years I was
three and thirty I'd be the same guy
three times no
Nathan II be you what's up me bro come
get this what's funny the only reason I
beat him is I didn't win my sophomore
year
oh and whatever ya know and then my
junior year my mom who never came to
anything she says yeah my mom will come
to your uh will come you wrestle match
this weak acid would I so I said
everybody on the team I go I can't lose
my mom's coming I can't lose my mom's
coming so all week my coach is anybody's
really working with me cuz I was really
bad I go I can't do it it's just give me
one move I just want one move and I'll
perfect it so they taught me the head
and arm you know that was like so all
week I'm working on a head norm head
Norman I'm right I'm like I got it I got
it I go out there I shake the guy's hand
[ __ ] tried to put me in a hand arm
but he missed it and then I got on him
13 seconds slow Oh
what's up Wow school record 13 second
mom sorry mom stands up and goes
wrestler in Ohio no the team like leg
lifts me up on their shoulders their is
so happy for my and Rudy and then it's
so funny so that was that's the first
time I beat them and then you know you
get the high school you got the
wrestling tournaments yeah and you got
the brackets there's eight teams in our
in our conference yeah some reason we
pull names out of a hat I get a buy the
first round so now I'm in the semis
Final Four this guy he wins so now I got
him in the semis I go got this [ __ ] in
the finals I go literally the guy was
wrestling I'll never forget his record
was like twenty nine and one and my shoe
was like one in 18 the [ __ ] out of here
yeah but my only thing was then was
don't get pinned because I was like
there's a lot of people here I don't
want to just go out like that
you smile any time in a fridge the whole
time my codes like after it is I got it
ain't happening you know my capabilities
man
talking to I wish they had a video I was
talking to my coach the whole match yeah
yeah go this ain't working
I can't do that yeah yeah you know what
I mean I got that hat then then you won
dint you win like best black coming in
San Diego crazy is that well they had a
radio station called z9t it was a
hip-hop station and I'm driving in my my
truck the same s10 pickup that I picked
my wife in and I hear this radio
commercial we're looking for the
funniest black comedians scene Diego no
like oh [ __ ] sorry pull over right the
phone number down called up said hey I'm
gonna hand her fearless I want to enter
they go alright so they go you know that
shows it somewhere in Imperial Beach
this little [ __ ] club show up of
course I'm only a white guy there there
was uh there was a Mexican guy there and
I go up and it was it could have been
the worst comedy show I've ever seen
from the hosts
everybody everybody was bad bad really
bad and then I sue it was an easy win
it was landslide it's like this so I got
I got this title that I just put on my
bio titled oh man gravity to it like it
wasn't that big of a deal if I did ride
away man I think that's dope
know what I mean but it is humility and
being really humble to to eat that much
[ __ ]